welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and the batman released a new
international trailer teasing new clues
for what sounds like three hours of
robert pattinson slothin new creepy
wayne obsessed vision boards new bat
tech also separately the funeral scene
to give us a sense of how well director
matt reeves has perfected this film
stone i am going to break it all down to
explain what you might have missed let's
get started like it or not it's rhythm's
game now
what are we looking for
more symbols
jesus's next victim is bruce wayne so
standing on the same ledge of the gcpd
still under construction upper level
where the bat signal sits batman says
like it or not we are in the riddler's
game now of course i think they were
always dealing with this riddler but now
the emphasis of the sentence is really
on the word game like even when this
riddler is locked up his game continues
which is probably why batman's so mad
then the riddler's wall that we saw a
close-up of in a pass trailer showing
photos of the wayne family seated beside
choirboy edward nashton covered with if
i only knew then what i know now
headlines about thomas wayne's past
mayoral campaign promises of renewing
gotham's orphanages and photos of adult
bruce wayne with behind him a creepy
smile that many of us think looks like
barry kyogen rumored to actually be the
joker of this movie instead of his
reported role of officer stanley merkel
but now in this trailer we see the full
wall the truth about gotham written
across the top in the upper left a
savage murder report referring to police
commissioner pete savage but this
newspaper headline maybe being an
unwitting pun because he's likely gonna
be one of the riddler's murder targets
another headline calls him top cop with
his mouth cut or burned out of the photo
maybe that could reflect how the riddler
murders them because we know this
riddler has some kind of torture device
apparatus that feeds directly into the
victim's mouth now to the upper left of
those savage headlines you could read
moroni drug bust the same headline that
was on mayor mitchell's wall in that
crime scene referring to sal moroney and
the moroni crime family rivals to
carmine falcone in his operation who i
think mayor mitchell may have had a
corrupt deal with to bust the maroneys
to make business better for the falcones
corruption that district attorney gil
coulson may also be part of because
moviemaker did an in-depth interview
with the cast and crew revealing that
the names coulson and mitchell coulson
specifically spelled with just an o not
the oh you the normal spelling is
actually a nod to the watergate scandal
in which political operative charles
coulson spelled just c-o-l-s-o-n and
attorney general john mitchell helped
president richard nixon cover up that
scandalous break-in of the democratic
headquarters at the watergate hotel
which eventually brought the whole nixon
administration down and when asked about
that matt reeves confirmed that this
story is actually one that exposes how
gotham itself is a sick corrupt place
now also on this wall we see police
sketches of the batman vigilante in
newspaper reports of his activity these
sketches were actually teased in a
promotional site set up for the film
later in this trailer a closer look of
this area shows headlines about spotting
the caped crusader that's batman's
longtime moniker in uptown and then
another quoting the mayor i don't care
what he's trying to do no one takes the
law into their own hands and then
another newspaper wondering if the
batman is friend or foe now zooming back
out there is another defaced campaign
signed thomas wayne for murderer and
then to the right of those edward wrote
i know dot dot i know the real you which
actually feels like a continuation of a
thought in his previous statement so
putting these together it's if i only
knew then what i know now i know i know
the real you but the word real is
underlined here which could tie it in
with this movie's word play in names
that appears to exist in pretty much
every character name of mayoral
candidate bella real and her slogan a
real change array all change but when we
step back from this wall it is clear
that this was presented by edward
nashton for the gcpd to find this whole
wall is a little puzzle to distract and
delay the police to spend all of their
time trying to decode when riddlers
really just planning to blow up
anyway from coulson's neck to the sea
walls of this city flooding it wiping
the slate clean from decades of unfair
city planning and to score some personal
revenge for nashton's inner scars from
those false promises of renewal as he
was likely an orphan who may have a
personal connection to the wayne family
now are you looking to up your smell
game but not looking to drain your bank
or spend a lot of time aimlessly
wandering around a fragrance aisle
avoiding those sniper spritzes gotcha
now you smell the way i want you to
smell thanks well scentbird is a
flexible fragrance subscription service
that lets you shop from over 600 brands
senford lets you choose a new designer
fragrance to try every month they have
perfumes and colognes and a lot of
unisex options you can discover new
fragrances by taking a simple quiz on
scentbird based on your preferences
previous purchases and quiz answers
they'll help you to find the fragrance
that you will love so i got a couple
fragrances this month and they come with
these little cards that tell you i
received sense of wood vetiver and oak
gucci made to measure robert cavalli i
liked him a lot but i mean gucci made me
feel pretty gucci it was just a really
nice scent it has kind of a spiciness
which the accompanying card says
includes lavender plum leather bergamot
and cinnamon match with sri lankan
nutmeg that's why i love it so much
nutmeg with these you just use this
really cool dispenser system and you
just like spray it here oh and just
spray it here
yep
it's a good amount of scent eight times
the amount of a normal sample and with
each fragrance you get a 30 day supply
so you can try out fragrances before
committing to a full bottle of it and
you can upgrade to receive two or three
products a month so make sure to use
nr55 for 55 off it's just seven dollars
for your first month of senford
available in the us and in canada and
thanks again to scentbird for sponsoring
this episode now then we see a crime
scene camera flashing on an actual bat
in a cage now i must be this was
actually the animal kept in nashton's
cages perhaps used to torture his
victims i thought it was gonna be a rat
but it sounds like it's gonna be a bat
but that trickery does line up with the
cipher at the end of all these trailers
which translates to you are el rata
alara which is spanish for you are the
winged rat and having this bat in the
crime scene is just another way that
national is calling out the batman
directly and if you think about it this
camera flash hits the bat as it
outstretches his wings which for a brief
second on the wall behind it would form
a literal bat signal there then we see
the most techie this batman's gear has
gotten an eye contact lens embedded with
nano circuitry to record everything
batman sees he places this contact lens
on an upload sensor and then a close-up
of bruce's bloodshot eyeball watching
back footage as if on another screen
maybe scrubbing back through all that
footage to see what he missed hey can i
get one of these when i watch this
three-hour movie so i don't have to
break it down for memory and don't have
to read poorly written notes scribbled
in the dark now other trailer footage
has shown red tinted photography taken
from a curved fisheye style lens
including that shot of selena kyle on
the screen behind him in the bat cave
which likely explains how brutes
captured all that imagery now if you
look at bruce's eyeball it looks like
reflected there is a screen that is
split three ways which looks a lot like
the layout gc1 used when that news
station reported the riddler's live
stream with batman putting the vertical
oriented phone in the middle making it
look like there were three frames there
we saw this in other trailer footage i'm
wondering if bruce may now be scanning
his lens footage for any in all
sightings of the riddler symbol around
the city that until this point he just
may have passed each night not thinking
anything of it and then gordon realizes
that the riddler is targeting bruce
wayne next though not yet clear if
gordon has himself put together that
bruce wayne is batman i mean let's think
about it both the batman and bruce wayne
are public figures in gotham city with
their own headlines it wouldn't be that
unusual for this serial killer to be
obsessed with both these figures even if
many of his printouts on his wall do put
the two right beside each other let's
move on it can be cruel poetic or blind
but when it's denied
it's your violence you may find
the answer's justice okay the voice of
the riddler really underlines the word
violence with some savagery if you're
violent you may find yes he chose
violence maybe when he recorded that he
exerted himself to commit a particular
violent act like taking the life of his
next victim now also released was the
full two-minute clip of the scene that
shows the funeral of mayor mitchell it
picks up with bella royale telling bruce
wayne that he could do more for city
confirming their context that she is now
running for mitchell's now empty seat
then bruce eavesdrop on lieutenant
gordon and chief mackenzie bach played
by con o'neil gil coulson is missing
what
he hasn't been heard from since last
night
christ not again hey
mr wayne and then when bruce has to turn
away awkwardly they all start hearing
this noise from outside
damn reef's direction and the editing
make this all so tense like we know
what's coming in the search ever since
that first teaser but still those sounds
of the faint screams and the gunshot
pops and the engine river just grows
louder and louder over these choir boys
singing ave maria and doing it this way
we feel what bruce and these other
funeral attendees feel like not here not
at a funeral we're in a church surely
this must be a safe place until it
becomes clear in this gotham and in the
riddler's game nowhere is safe you can
support new rockstars by checking out
our merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram twitter at eavos follow new
rockstars and subscribe to rockstars for
more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching batman
[Music]
you